have you seen um
companies transform
because they have figured this out what
their what the why really is and how to
communicate it in such a way that it
becomes quite powerful
the simple answer is of course
um you know companies that were uh
maybe just financially driven
shareholder that's all it was money
money money no purpose no cause
underlying
people liked the job you know everything
was fine nobody loved it you know
did they they didn't necessarily trust
leadership even though they may get
along with them
um and when when when uh when the cause
becomes
uh clearly articulated and visceral it's
visceral for the leaders as well and so
you ask me sort of what's the right way
to communicate it the the interesting is
you know what's the right way to talk
about your kids what's the right way to
talk about your marriage i'm like well
if it's a successful marriage and you
love your kids you ooze with passion you
know when somebody starts talking about
their marriage and it's not doing so
well like we can tell like we can tell
when the passion's not there um and it's
it's the same for work which is if you
truly have a love
if the leadership truly has a belief
in the mission that you're trying to
advance i don't need to give you an
instruction manual on how to talk about
it it'll pour out of you in fact quite
the opposite we'll have to like get you
to stop
right um
i think the one thing that i a lot of
leaders miss the opportunity or they
take for granted
is is meetings quite frankly which is
when we start a meeting
um let's say it's it's reviewing about
the budget right so everybody comes in
and like all right let's pull out the
budget and pull out us you know
the excel sheet and we'll start looking
at the numbers but no context is ever
given and i'm a great believer that you
should start every meeting to the point
that people make fun of you reminding
people why this meeting exists
what's the purpose of this meeting it's
not actually the budget right
guys we wake up every single day to find
the cure for cancer it's it's the thing
that drives every single one of us and
if we do well financially we have the
fuel
to achieve our goal if we don't do well
financially then we will then right
there we're not going to find a cure for
cancer we will not be able to contribute
at all so the reason we're having this
budget meeting is to make sure that
everything's on track and to make sure
that we're we're that this is advancing
that because when we leave that context
out it all becomes about this and that's
when we get that myopia that's when we
then we get that finite mindset where we
can we can't see past the numbers so
it's up to the leaders to the point
where others make fun of them so mark
this this is a practical tip we have 400
leaders listening yeah and let's say
there are five meetings a day 200 days a
year that's a uh a thousand times 400
400 000 opportunities in the next 12
months to reinforce yeah to reinforce
and i mean i mean i'm obsessive about it
like the powerpoint the one page of your
powerpoint presentation gets more uh
that gets a longer read than any other
page
is the cover page because it's up on the
screen while we're waiting for the
meeting to start everybody's just sort
of hanging out there it is on the screen
every day just waiting every other page
is just a minute each
you know three four five minutes we're
just sitting reading that page and we're
sitting on someone's desk just you know
just lying there and it just says budget
you know 2021 budget you know that's
what marketing plan that's all it says
so i'm a great believer that that the
cover of that page um should be the big
bold words of the context why we're
doing this and the small words
underneath are and the money we need to
do it and the marketing plan we need to
do it and this year's you know hr uh
plan to do it but but that cause needs
to be front and center all the time